foreign
yeah uh it is Easter today
um and we celebrated by having a
Thanksgiving dinner for lunch it wasn't
the full boat Thanksgiving it was just a
turkey with dressing gravy cranberry
sauce homemade cranberries which is yeah
all the main mashed potatoes of
Thanksgiving yeah so I didn't have the
cream style corn didn't have the uh
pecan pie didn't have the no pumpkins
though no pumpkin stuff no uh
what else is oh no rolls no dinner rolls
yeah it was just but still it was
awesome
the main stuff didn't have the damn
green bean casserole with the damn
onions on top that's okay
I know it's very I know that's a very
controversial opinion to have in the
United States not having that yeah I
don't hate it I don't really it's it's
not really I don't usually eat it yeah
Thanksgiving Thanksgiving with Mexicans
involves tamales
well you know yeah that'd be good too
and the Italians are eating whole
lasagnas Thanksgiving that's probably
turkey and lasagna I guess
sure why not we're to Turkey in the
lasagna yes I mean that could probably
work too turkey lasagna put some tamales
inside the turkey yeah yeah it'll be
like a turducken except for Tamales and
lasagna yeah yeah that's a Mala turkeys
uh tamales for [__] Christmas and
tamales for
well tamales are good thanks what do you
want me to do about it yeah it's
Mexican-American
all right so as promised we received the
Blu-ray in the mail yesterday of Fargo
yeah from zanada so thank you very much
xanada for sending that uh Sanders my
boy I talked to him online all time as I
said lives out in the desert and I help
him with his AR-15 builds and his
[__] load his desert survival Loadout
he's a good dude
yeah he uh sent me a message and said if
I send you Fargo will you make Tom watch
it yeah I watched it
I had seen parts of it but I had never
seen the whole thing I didn't know right
I didn't know it was Fargo that I was
seeing because I feel like a couple
scenes out of it you've seen because you
haven't seen a lot of Coen Brothers
films I haven't seen all of them I've
seen most of them
but um you really really like The Big
Lebowski yeah and um now see I love
Raising Arizona you did not like Raising
Arizona all that much
um but
oh maybe we should do Barton Fink one of
these days that's a [__] weird ass
movie that was the one that they did
actually it wasn't the one before Fargo
it was the one prior to the one before
that because the one they did before
Fargo was the hot sucker proxy which I
remember seeing and that was one with
Tim Robbins and I remember really liking
it but I don't really remember much
about it I think I saw that in the
theater
but it's interesting because Fargo this
came out in 1996. I think I saw this in
the theater as well now that I'm
thinking about it
and what had happened was that you have
to thank the Coen Brothers I mean
they're very famous nowadays obviously
but back in the 90s they were still kind
of considered sort of like indie or like
cult filmmakers you know what I mean
they did everything like independently
like outside of the Hollywood System so
they had made I believe five movies at
this point they made Blood Simple which
I reviewed um not too long ago and
actually Blood Simple is kind of similar
uh thematically to uh Fargo
which I'll get into in a bit and they
had made a couple other ones like I said
they made Barton Fink they made Raising
Arizona they made the HUD sucker proxy
which was actually kind of supposed to
be their big budget whatever I think it
was like 27 million dollars which is a
lot of money for them but it completely
completely Tanked and so after that I
guess they decided to go back to their
roots
I think I heard that they went back to
the producers after the HUD sucker proxy
did horribly like at the box office I
think it only made like a tenth of its
budget back and they showed the
producers the script for Fargo which
they'd been working on for a couple
years I was like I don't think you
should make this but next this is the
weirdest [__] [__] I've ever read
um but as it turned out they were given
the opportunity to make Fargo for you
know uh only seven million dollars and
it was a massive massive success uh not
only critically but also audience and it
was nominated for seven Oscars including
best picture it didn't win but uh
Francis McDormand won best actress and
it also won best original screenplay
yeah it's a Trippy flick it's a true
crime drama I [__] love this but it's
also kind of like a comedy and kind of
but it's a dark comedy yeah man it's
also kind of realistic and
um having lived in Michigan this this is
taking place I think in Minnesota right
yeah yeah but it's it's Midwest and it
the culture yeah that's that's the world
the Coen brothers are from Minnesota
yeah so they're kind of
misconfectionately
satirizing the culture they grew up in
parts of Michigan are kind of like that
and the accents and everything aren't
quite that bad in Michigan but some
people have them it's funny because like
when Sophie comes to visit you know what
I mean and that every now and then that
accent comes out of her yeah and brings
me back to living in Michigan I forgot
how
how funny people sell to their it's for
the people that don't live in the United
States that
the mid uh the Midwest Upper Midwest
Upper Midwest it's a different ethnic
makeup as say versus the South or
Northeast or Southwest or you know
they're more kind of Scandinavian uh you
got a lot of Swedish people of Swedish
descent they think there may have been
Vikings there at one point in the past
but I don't know
they found some stones and [__] they
it's difficult to say they thought that
maybe some Vikings made it to the Great
Lakes back in ancient times
but um
the uh they're kind of uh Nordic you
know like Scandinavian mixed with Slavic
people and Hungarian people but a lot
mostly mostly uh Swedish types and
Slavic people that's that's really the
main
ethnic group there you know and they
they're they're tall
and you can go back and look at when
Sophie was on or the guest I want to
show you can see what they look like
they just look like something out of
Sweden kind of
tall blonde
but they had that funny accent and it
does sound like a mutated Swedish accent
it does a bit it's kind of like musical
sounding yeah and uh you know you don't
get really a lot of movies made about
this particular area of the United
States which I think was something that
a lot of people really responded to yeah
I think you know like I said critically
this was you know an almost universally
Beloved movie I feel like the only the
people that didn't like it their main
criticism was they thought that the Coen
brothers were making fun of the
characters or making fun of like people
from the Upper Midwest and I'm like I
don't I didn't really get that
impression I understand it because
Southerners think the same thing when
they portray Southerners you know what I
mean sometimes it comes off as they're
making fun of the South
um so they thought they were making fun
of it but the thing is is that in the
stereotypes there's a lot of Truth in
the stereotypes there's a lot of Truth
in stereotypes about the south there's a
lot of Truth in the stereotypes what
they were talking about in the in this
movie from Minnesota and the the you
know the uh the Midwest yeah it's they
kind of show the the people and the
in the culture kind of accurately yeah I
mean it's not bad it's slightly
exaggerated for the movie like First
comedy slightly comedic effect but not
really all that much I don't feel like
yeah and the thing about it is that you
know the Francis mcdormand's character
uh you know Marge Gunderson you know I I
don't know where you would get off if
they think they was making fun of her
she is clearly the hero of the piece I
mean she is the movie's moral Center and
she's a delightful delightful character
what makes the hero so cool
and it seems very this isn't like
something that you nowadays
Hollywood a lot of the shit's made like
by by a committee and you got certain
demographics be the male female or white
black or whatever they're like their
shoe horned into these roles it seems
kind of inorganic this seems very
organic
the hero of the movie is a cop who she's
kind of a when you look at she's a
pregnant female cop
and on the surface she comes across as
kind of mediocre but she does a hell of
a job and does some Brave [__] would you
would you really and she's like a deeply
good person yeah she's a good person
yeah and I think that's why people
really responded to her character in
such a way because she's just so
endearing yeah and she cut and she's
like a very average
police investigator average cop for uh
from that culture and end that time back
in the 90s
so she's very kind of average but
you see how competent average was she
she was good yeah that's the thing she's
kind of like she's sharp as a tech yeah
but
you'd be forgiven for thinking that
maybe she wasn't because of the way like
culturally those you know she comes
across yeah she comes across as kind of
like
in a certain way and just go oh well you
know yeah you know that she's like she's
not
[Laughter]
I'm not really taking this thing no she
yeah and I
and that's the coolest thing about her
character is that overtly like on the
surface she doesn't seem like an overtly
heroic character but she absolutely is
a hero she's like the hero guy on the
road and everything yeah and she's like
not afraid of them or anything like that
and I thought that was like I thought
that was really well done but it's very
very low-key I like the way that that
was the dude that she ends up arresting
is the [__] psycho yeah he's a
[__] nut all right and uh she arrests
him and it's not some you know something
like out of Sucker Punch where she's in
a mini skirt [__] killing millions of
[__] World War One Nazis like they
had Nazis in World War one it's not like
that
it's not superhero [__] it's just like
yeah that's how it would have went down
well she's just relax I think the reason
like I said I think the reason a lot of
people responded to her character in
such a positive way is because she's
just like an ordinary person oh yeah but
you know she's a deeply good person
she's a deeply moral person and she
steps up to the plate when [__] has to
get done she does it yeah you know what
I mean stop the bad guys right and and
it's because honestly one of my favorite
scenes in the movie
is after you know spoiler alert
obviously from a movie that's you know
that this old at this point but um after
she catches uh Peter stormar's character
you know at the end
when he's putting Steve Buscemi into the
wood chipper and she you know shoots him
in the leg and takes them alive and
everything like that it's like the
little kind of speech she gives him in
the police car when he's in the back I
love that she's like not
she's not really like yelling at her him
or she's not like overly emotional or
anything she's just very disappointed
yeah she's just very disappointed and
it's like you know all these people are
dead and all these legs like and for
what a little bit of money yeah and
that's what she said she's trying to
reason with him right right just for
some money just for some money yeah
she's like you know there's more to life
than a little bit of money don't you
know that yeah yeah you know she's just
very very disappointed yeah and I like
the fact I think she plays and you know
her Best Actress Oscar was well deserved
I think because she finds like a really
good balance between
being
I don't want to say naive I don't think
she's naive necessarily because I mean
she's a cop but she's kind of in this
small town and it seems like she
probably doesn't deal with this kind of
thing a lot but she's aware that there's
evil in the world
um you know so it's not
it's shocking to her I guess but she
still has the capacity to be like
disappointed by it and be like hope that
people would do better and I think that
she really kind of like struck a good
balance of that and like I said I think
that's why a lot of people responded
positively to her character because
she's just she's just such a nice person
like a genuinely nice person she's just
and I love like the interactions with
her and her husband Norm like who's
played by John Carroll Lynch I forgot
that he was in this because it's been a
while since I've seen it but they're
just so regular and it's like they're
not super like effusive they're not
super emotional which like I said that's
another thing that's very characteristic
of the Upper Midwest they're very
they're very overtly nice and stuff like
that but they're very kind of
emotionally
distant I want to say or they're not
like they're overly yeah they're very
reserved that was the word that I was
looking for like I said I've never been
to the Midwest personally but um a lot
of my knowledge of the Midwest comes
from Mystery Science Theater because a
lot of them are from Minnesota and they
kind of like make fun of that the same
way that Joel and Eva I was talking
about it with Sophie the other day I was
thinking maybe me and you
ought to go up there and go clubbing
with soap and we'll swing by and visit
Steve and grab this hammer
yeah you got to do that sometime you've
never seen it but the thing is is that I
would not go up there in the winter
well yeah we want to go up there during
the summer yeah Winter's a pain in the
ass just to getting just getting around
is a [__] yeah I can imagine yeah
yeah because like what like 30 below
zero or something yeah just all the
[__] snow and all roads are salted
and [__] yeah it's just it's just not
pleasant and ironically when they were
filming this movie
they're like Well normally because like
I said the cohens they don't live there
anymore but they grew up in Minnesota
so they're like we we wanted it to look
like this white like white it out
hellscape where there's like nothing
around and where the you know setting
became like its own character and
they're like the year that we were
shooting it was like the warmest winter
on record for like or the second warmest
winter for like 100 years or something
like that and it's like there wasn't
enough snow like what we wanted to say
to truck in like fake snow and then they
had to shoot it they had to go like all
over North Dakota because somebody was
saying yeah Fargo is in North Dakota and
that's the thing they asked them why
they're like okay well why is the movie
called Fargo because only literally only
I think the first scene where William H
Macy's character Jerry is setting up the
whole kidnapping plot like with the two
lowlifes that's the only scene that
happens in Fargo North Dakota the rest
of it happens in Brainerd Minnesota yeah
but uh so they asked the cohens about
that and they said Well Fargo sounds
like a better title than Brainerd does
it yeah that was basically the only
reason that they gave which I thought
was like seeing something up there the
two bimbos with poofy hair who bang
Steve Buscemi yes thank you xanada yeah
uh whoops it kind of went it's not
letting me uh scroll up um remind me of
poofy-haired bimbos I would pick up at
Michigan bars back in my pipeline yeah
yeah that's what we went to school with
a lot of them girls well it's like and I
remember like seeing a couple of um they
kind of reminded me of that of that
chick from remember that Kitchen
Nightmares that they did yeah I think it
was in Minnesota yeah and it's like one
of the women that worked in the
restaurant The Waitresses like it was
kind of like that that's what it
reminded me but yeah those two were
[__] hilarious they were only in one
scene they were like yeah they were call
girls and uh you know Marge is
interviewing them and she's like you
know I was banging the little one he was
kind of funny looking yeah he's like
well can you be more specific what you
know what do you mean funny look I don't
know just funny looking yeah
and then like as far as call them call
girls they were probably just more like
hoes Yeah well yeah I also like they
were rough they were just they were
pretty what the deal was that was a
pretty accurate portrayal of just like
the Baseline average
once you get out of the bigger cities in
in in in in in say like around in the
Michigan areas
um you know up up in the midwest kind of
like what you would call Hillbillies yes
they're just kind of like that they're
almost kind of like Canadians or
something but well it is very close yeah
so yeah
but uh but like real country
Northern country
and it has its own thing because it's
there's kind of an industrial touch to
it because they were doing heavy
industry up there you know that area was
kind of like
America's version of Siberia with
[__] tanko Grodd and all the [__]
where all the Russian factories were we
had the same thing here
the steel industry was there making cars
uh and then the things that we went into
cars and I think there was a bunch of
coal and Mining going on and they're
just they're country but they're
Industrial
industrial workers not so much Farmers
they had them but Industries where it
was
but I was going to say that um I also
think it's funny that you know when she
was talking about Steve Buscemi being
funny looking and I like that they
called that back later on like with that
random witness who was saying that he
saw a funny looking little guy and the
other cop is asking that guy too he's
like well what do you mean funny looking
just funny looking in a general way like
nobody could like specify how he was
funny looking
and they kept asking them to be more
specific and they couldn't
um Ben asked oh I wanted to talk about
this actually have you seen kamiko the
treasure hunter I haven't but I've heard
about it a very sad Japanese film about
a young woman obsessed with Fargo so she
steals her boss's credit card and
travels there because she thinks she
knows where the bag of cash is in real
life yeah that's okay
so at the beginning you could be
forgiven for thinking that this story
for this movie was based on a true story
it's not exactly
but they thought it would be funny to
put a thing at the beginning saying this
is based on a true story like everything
is as accurate as possible
um and they've kind of gone back and
forth over the years over whether it's
actually based on our truth so there
were a couple of crimes there was one I
think that maybe happened in Connecticut
or something like that like in the 60s
where a guy did like pay to have his
wife killed and they did put her in a
wood chip or [__] like that but there
was nothing like this that happened in
Minnesota in 1987 like it says so they
kind of like just made it up
now one thing that happened and this
kind of turned into an urban legend now
this is true there was a Japanese a
young Japanese woman who came to
Minneapolis from Tokyo I believe and
they found her dead
out in the Wilds in Minnesota
and because of something that she had
said to someone like a cop or something
like that and she didn't speak a lot of
English
um somebody thought that she believed
that the movie Fargo was true and so
that consequently you know there's a
part in the film where Steve Buscemi's
character buries a suitcase with almost
a million dollars in it like out in the
snow and so the urban legend arose that
she had actually come here looking for
that money because she thought that it
was a true story and then like she died
while she was looking for the money that
is actually not true um she did come
here and she did die but they discovered
that she had probably just committed
suicide she actually sent a suicide note
and it didn't have anything to do with
Fargo but there was kind of like an
urban legend about that that she thought
the movie was true that like she found
them but yeah they made a whole movie
about it called kamiko the treasure
hunter it's funny that you're talking
about Steve Buscemi being funny looking
hey grandpars grandpas will remember
what I'm talking about my other best
friend was a dude named Mike Kowalski
and when I wasn't hanging out with Steve
I was hanging out with Mike Mike was a
spitting image of a young [__] Steve
Buscemi
looked just like that what's funny is
when he grew up he got big though he
[__] [__] turned into a damn
hook he looked like [__] Anthony
Michael Hall did out of the [__]
was a dead zone Series so he looked like
when he grew up
ran his own crime investigation team
forensics cleanup what he did
but yeah so uh if I didn't say thank you
very much xanada for sending us the
movie and also the Super Chat we are a
very passive aggressive in the midwest
yes I've heard that yeah um you know
because you you all would want to be
polite at all times but you're kind of
like hiding the seething resentment
underneath yeah I've heard that uh
thanks for reviewing this one hopefully
Tom didn't hate it it's the only movie
about my home state oh no I liked it
yeah I thought you might yeah I liked it
I thought you might to me this seems
like a combination like I don't know
maybe this is a little glib to say this
but this almost seems like a combination
of Blood Simple which is their first
movie and Raising Arizona because like
Raising Arizona you have like the kind
of black comedy you have the kidnapping
scheme that goes horribly awry and like
all these weird characters and it's very
like Regional but then Blood Simple is
kind of like a Noir so it's sort of like
a combination of those two things but
like in the best possible way
um granther said yeah come up to God's
country no salt no sharks no problems
then Xander said the accent is like
Nordic or Canadian yeah yeah
Ben said for a long time I thought the
Dakotas were just north of Florida for
some reason no oh hell no they're way
far away that's the Virginia's that's
north of Florida
well what's just north of Florida is
Georgia Georgia
and then the Virginia and then well the
Carolinas yeah yeah yeah there's
Virginia and then there's West Virginia
yeah which is pretty small that's what I
meant but he's talking about the Dakotas
yeah the Dakotas are way over in the
middle yes
uh Oracle says it's definitely grounded
in reality though the Minnesota nice
reality I think that's what always
like I said I kind of feel like this is
maybe the only movie that explores this
area it's a very unexplored area of the
United States like at least in movie Dum
it's mostly boring well yeah and I think
that's why but it's I still think it's
like a fascinating culture to explore
because like I said I think it was
genius to kind of counter pose this sort
of like overtly like very emotionally
reserved and very overtly polite the
whole quote-unquote Minnesota nice thing
against this horrific True Crime
kidnapping scheme that goes horrible and
a lot of like all these people end up
brutally murdered and stuff like that I
think that was like a genius move and I
can see how because the humor in this
it's very dark humor it's very deadpan
which a lot of their movies are so I can
kind of see how because I think this
movie is hilarious but I can see how
like some people might not and it's not
just because of their accents either
it's just like the whole
the whole situation of it is just absurd
to me like I said the juxtaposition of
these types this type of culture this
type of personality and like the the
situation that unfolds is like really
funny just the pacing of the story and
the pacing of what happens in it
but it's true to it's true to the
Midwest especially wintertime the pace
in Winter and in in say Michigan or the
Midwest is slow everything slows down
because transportation is difficult
and
ha it seems like seems like for the
whole winter it kind of
doesn't shut down but it slows a lot you
know what I mean and this is what it
would be like investigating a crime
in that
and it kind of becomes depressing it's
dark a lot
and for some reason
every time I go back to Michigan every
time I go back to Michigan I went back
several times after I left to visit
Steve
I keep hearing Bob Seger in my head
if you listen to Bob Seger depressing as
[__] you just wanted to shut the [__] up
and that's kind of [__] the way
Michigan in the winter [__] feels
like a Bob Seger song you know I'm on
the road again yeah Turn Turn the Page
shut the [__] up yeah he's crying over
[__] it's like that
Graveler says I cringe whenever I see
the scene where Steve buscember gets
shot in the jaw and goes around patching
it with napkins that injury would
[__] hurt yeah actually I had
forgotten about that scene and so like
when it happened I was like oh [__] it's
like just raised his [__] face and
they did a good job like doing [__] I
don't know if grabther's seen any facial
[__] gunshots or seen videos of
people have been shot in the face it's a
[__] painful uh wound
because it's just a bunch of bone and
nasal cavity a lot of nerve endings and
[__] teeth and your tongues in there
and it's not a vital area people when
somebody's shooting at somebody else
they tend to aim for the eyes and the
brain is not at the eyes it's quite
above it a lot of times the round lands
in the face and it just busts the dudes
up and it doesn't kill them they walk
around just like that
oh imagine you had a toothache like just
like a million times
flaps you know depending on what caliber
it was teeth [__] busted out you know
yeah
you don't really want to get shot
anywhere but you definitely don't want
to get shot in the face
yeah and Ben says it bleeds like crazy
too yeah bleeds like [__] yeah
anything that's like face or headwinds
yeah bleed a lot all those blood vessels
and all those nerve endings up in there
yeah and it's like even if it's like not
right it's like it's like an alarming
amount of blood like even if the injury
is not that bad it's an alarming amount
of blood
um but yeah I was gonna say oh I wanted
to say too that uh Peter Stormare who is
the actor that played um you know the
the other Hitman
uh gear was his name right the the big
hulking mute guy uh he's actually
Swedish and he said that when he was in
Minnesota like shooting the movie like
he went to all these places because you
know there's a place in Minnesota called
Stockholm and there's always and he
wanted to go on and he said that
Minnesota is like more Sweden than
Sweden that's yeah more Swedish than
Sweden is but he thought it was like
really cool that like he went around and
everyone was like super super well we've
touched on this subject many times here
in the show and you know I've had people
girls from from who came from Israel
living in Greece saying man had no idea
that America was so diverse because a
lot of foreigners just think it's all
the same thing no the place is [__]
huge and it's more like four or five big
regions all shoved together
trying to make peace with each other you
know but uh yeah the Northeast is like
Sweden or mixed with like some Slavic
area like Poland mixed in there you know
because uh Mike was a Polish descent
and uh when you're talking in the South
it's kind of more like Irish and Germans
that was that's the base Irish Germans
and French a little bit of Spanish but
then you had people who are direct
Spanish descendants Florida used to be
part of Spain
um
Louisiana was was owned by France for a
long time but it was also owned by Spain
before then so it's just it's just a
each region has its own history its own
blend of people
the oldest kind of married together you
just becoming your own kind of ethnic
group but they move around a lot
especially recently everybody's moving
like Florida a lot of people are here
now are not from here I'm not from here
I'm from basically my family's Southern
Mississippi and Virginia
but uh
I'm sure I had ancestors in Florida too
though well it's been like that forever
because I remember when I when I was
growing up I was one of the only people
I knew that was actually born in Florida
I mean I know a lot of people were but
um I didn't really know that many people
that were born in Florida everybody
moved here from somewhere what I'm
seeing now go down to the [__] biker
bar dudes from New York
they're not from New York City they're
from New York State
they've moved here they're just running
from New York
well like I said I knew a lot of people
from New York when I was a kid like I've
always known people from and mostly from
um New York state or
um Ohio I know a lot of people that
moved here from Ohio places like that
Illinois
stuff like that
um yeah xanadas said Minnesota nice is
definitely real yeah like I've like I've
heard and he said uh nobody wants to be
confrontational in that culture Tom
would hate it yeah like I said it's very
very passive aggressive because
everybody just has to maintain like
politeness at all times granther says
the wood chipper scene is classic yeah
and I kind of feel like that was the one
that everybody kind of referred to I
love that Marge like peeks around the
tree and sees what's happening she's
like the leg like sticking out of the
wood chipper and him like trying to cram
it in with the with the log or whatever
and she's just like shocked for a second
but then she immediately like regains
her a plum and she's just kind of like
putting and then she just like [__]
shoots him in the leg when he starts
running away and then later on she just
very casually just says oh and I guess
that was your partner and the wood
chipper there you know what I mean like
it was the most adorable thing in the
world
um let's see wait Ben says was a simple
plan a remake of Fargo never saw it but
it looked pretty similar no um a simple
plan was actually uh quite different
and uh it was actually based on a novel
by Scott Smith and I've actually
reviewed both like on my over on my uh
flickers of fear and my other series I
did a review of the book by Scott Smith
which is excellent and the movie which I
think came out in 1993 that had Billy
Bob Thornton in them in it and uh the
movie is also really good and it's like
a really close um adaptation but it's
kind of similar in the sense that
um it's not a kidnapping though it's
like um guys it's two guys and they find
like a blur three guys and they find
like a crash plane that has like a bunch
of money in it and then they have like
this game where they're gonna keep the
money and like don't you know and no and
then like obviously everything horribly
goes wrong but it's kind of like a
similar kind of thing in that regard
where it's like a crime that keeps like
escalating and escalating but it's a
completely different story it doesn't
have anything to do with kidnapping
um somebody asks let me see uh Oracle
asked what is everybody's theories about
why Jerry needed the money
thought and maybe I'm okay maybe I'm
totally wrong about this but there's
remember there's a scene in the movie
where Jerry gets this phone call and I
think he gets another phone call like
later on the movie but he gets a phone
call from uh someone who's asking him
about so like yo what are all these
serial numbers for all these cars that
he supposedly sold and he got like all
this money for them and you're led to
believe that these cars don't exist and
he was just like making up the serial
numbers like to get the money from these
fictitious sales and I thought that he
had done that and then like he got like
this scheme was getting found out so
he's like well I need the money to
because I thought he'd been embezzling
from the company which the company was
owned by his father-in-law in case that
wasn't
um clear so I guess he was kind of like
embezzling money from his father-in-law
and needed to put it back before he got
caught I thought that's what it was but
maybe not maybe that's kind of maybe I
was missing because the ransom was only
was a million right well yeah initially
what he said he said that he was going
to because he only told the lowlifes
like the criminals he told them 80 000
and that he was going to split it 50 50
with them right but then he told the dad
he told Wade that the that it was a
million dollars so then he was going to
keep the leftover okay the pay what he
owes and then pay them what he had but
he told them that it was an 80 000 but
he was actually asking for a million
from the dad what he owed with their
money right yeah that yeah that's what
I'm saying yeah so also uh William H
Macy I think this he had been in stuff
before this but I'm pretty sure this was
like his kind of breakout role and I was
watching there's a documentary called
Minnesota nice which is about the making
of this movie and it's about half hour
long it's good and
um William H Macy wanted this part so
bad they said he actually came in and
read for a smaller part like the part of
like the state trooper who's only in
like one or two scenes and he came in to
read for that and he said one of the one
of the cohens asked him it's like oh do
you want to read for Jerry like the main
part and he's like hell yeah I would
like to do that and um so he read for it
they asked him to come back the next day
and he came back and read the next day
and then he said he wanted that part so
bad he said I was born to play this part
and um so when he heard that they had
gone back to New York and were doing
more casting there he actually used his
own money to fly out to New York to
basically get in their faces and go I'm
gonna have this part like let me read
for you again so they let him do it but
I think the coolest thing about again
about his character is that
Jerry's character he's a terrible
terrible person
but the way that he I think the the
thing that makes his character so great
is he's almost like you almost kind of
feel sorry for him because he seems like
such a schlub and he seems like he has
that whole Minnesota nice thing going on
like he's always just unfailingly polite
unfailingly deferential but he's just
setting up this horror it's almost like
a banality like a banality of evil thing
where it's just kind of like you can't
believe that a dude who seems this nice
would do these like just atrocious
monstrous I mean he's basically his wife
had nothing to do with anything she
didn't do anything to anybody and he's
basically like yeah I'm just gonna have
her kidnapped and like get all this
money and she ended up killing her yeah
and she just ends up being you know she
ends up getting killed and a bunch of
other innocent people end up getting
killed and you know and he doesn't even
really seem all that bothered all he's
worried about is just getting that money
because he's just so desperate if
somebody asked what do you think he
originally embezzled for it unclear I
guess huh well that's what we were just
talking about I I said about the whole
um the whole uh thing where the guy on
the phone was like asking him for the
serial numbers yeah I assumed that he
had an embezzling scheme going where he
was doing fictitious Car Sales yeah but
what was he doing with the money
they said well they just wanted to leave
it vague like he just needs the money
like he's in debt somehow
um you know what I mean they just kind
of left it vague yeah because he
obviously he already had his own house
he didn't need the money he didn't seem
to be
running from the wife maybe he was going
to divorce the wife or run for the wife
and take the money with him yeah I'm not
really sure because the thing about it
is that
um you know the the father-in-law was
really rich
and so I'm assuming there's one just
kind of offhand line in there where you
know he's um where Jerry's trying to
convince the father-in-law to get in on
this you know investment deal that he's
gonna do which is you know what he what
he was gonna do before he decided to
desperately do the kidnapping thing yeah
and so the dad doesn't want to do it and
then the dad says something to the
effective it's like well you know Gene
and Scotty who's the son oh they never
have to worry because they're always
going to be taken care of because the
dad is Rich and he'll take care but he's
gonna give a [__] about Jerry yeah I
mean you kind of like I said you almost
kind of feel bad for Jerry because the
father-in-law treats him like such a
loser yeah but then you can't really
feel sorry for him because he's just
like a terrible person like why would
you do that to and the thing about it he
was gonna buy that law
remember well yeah I know maybe that's
what he's gonna do with the money buy
that lot and that that's that's that was
going to be his future right he was
going to make this big investment and
that's why like he introduced it to them
because he needed the money like you
know from the dad and Stan well no they
thought it was a good deal but they just
said oh we'll just give you a finder's
fee because we're going to take it out
yeah that's right that's right remember
and then he was just like oh [__] then
he had to go ahead with the kidnapping
thing well the thing about it was that
he was gonna go ahead with the
kidnapping thing and then like the dad
and Stan the the accountant they were
like oh no this is a good deal so he's
like oh good maybe I don't have to do
the kidnapping thing but he couldn't he
couldn't call off the kidnapping because
he didn't have the dude's phone number
yeah because remember he got it through
Shep who was like a mechanic at the at
the car lot and like he couldn't get
hold of him so he couldn't like get hold
of him to tell him not to do it so they
just went ahead and did it anyway
shipped a mechanic at the car lot was it
was a native played by a native american
guy who looks familiar as [__] I think
that was he in Dances with Wolves I
don't know I haven't seen that before
comment section might know
but uh that guy looks real familiar
either that or he was in one of those
war movies like code talkers or
something
yeah maybe yeah or something like that
he was I think he was I think he was in
the war movie where they were fighting
the Japanese
Oracle said Jerry needs the money to
make himself feel less emasculated by
his father-in-law yeah there you go
probably yeah and then Ben said
Investments is likely where the money
went stupid people can lose money lose
any amount to pyramid schemes to good be
true opportunities yeah that maybe was
what they were implying because he
seemed like he was always kind of trying
to come up with some money making scheme
so I guess she could be led to believe
that sometime in the past he had
invested some money in his game and lost
it all because it was stupid uh grandpar
said the father-in-law had no time for
Jerry he knew Jerry was all clown shoes
yeah
um and holy Parish of Doom says the Wade
character is a real douche too though he
is I agree and the fact of the matter is
that
um I'm not saying that obviously the the
plot would have gone sideways anyway
because it started getting going
sideways even before Wade got involved
but Wade's insistence on taking the
money to the kidnappers himself
um obviously I got him killed uh might
have probably also got his daughter
killed as well but you know so that
because he was just well it's my money
so I'm gonna even though you know uh
Jerry was telling him no it's my deal
you know and he just had to like take
over yeah you guys daughter killed yeah
I mean I don't know the daughter the
daughter might have killed anyway before
the money showed up remember
well yeah well this one what's his name
when they found him
yeah because when he when the Steve
Buscemi guy went back to The Hideout she
was already dead wasn't she yeah
Garrett just shot her because right so
she was making noise so he would have
just showed up with the money
yeah here's the money you know I mean oh
she's dead yeah that's what so it
wouldn't have mattered it's kind of
interesting too the way and I was
reading an interview with the cohens
about this movie specifically and they
kind of went into like a lot of
um depth about what the you know what
they're what they were thinking when
they were writing it and
um I thought it was an interesting
decision to make Gene she's not really
in it much she's only like it you know
that's the wife that gets kidnapped
and she's only in a couple scenes at the
beginning like interacting with uh the
kid and with her dad and everything like
that but then once she gets kidnapped
she becomes sort of like depersonalized
like almost an object and they said they
kind of did that deliberately
um you know I guess because I think it
was mirroring Jerry's disregard of her
safety well she also became faceless she
never saw her face she was always in
that bag interestingly uh because that
wasn't the same actress anymore yeah
that was actually I think that was the
person that he'd laugh at her yeah
because she was losing it horrible yeah
but yeah so that's the thing I think
that they did that they didn't say this
outright but I think they were implying
pretty strongly that they did that
deliberately like I said to sort of
mirror Jerry's attitude toward her
because he obviously didn't give a [__]
to to him she was just like a means to
an end right and and another thing too
is that he also didn't really seem to
give much of a [__] about his son
because when when they said like after
you know she gets kidnapped and
everything and he's talking to Wade or
uh or Stan like the accountant and
they're like oh well how's Scotty going
to take this and he like he's taken
aback like he forgot about his son first
oh yeah I guess I got to tell her that
his mom got kidnapped her name was Jean
yeah like it didn't even occur Jane also
got herself killed too though because
she didn't even talk to those the guys
who abducted her she just screamed the
whole time and she basically kind of
like personified herself
they would probably that dude probably
would have been less nap to kill her
you know what I mean yeah but that guy
was a psycho and he was a psycho he just
killed people like just [__] randomly
that he didn't even need to yeah but I
think it would have been well it just
it's just a fictional story anyway yeah
yeah yeah but you know oracle said his
wife was essentially dead once she was
taken from the house in my opinion yeah
uh and also said Gene has a lot of
frantic energy for all of her scenes
she's like a jittery toy yeah and also I
think Gene was desperate to have Jerry
pay attention to her yeah yeah I mean
even in the scenes before she gets
kidnapped she's always
like frenetically like doing something
like she's always like chopping
vegetables really fast or like stirring
something really fast or she's always
like super nervous yeah she's always
like super nervous like that and I I
honestly kind of love too like the scene
where she's just like sitting in the
living room like when the kidnappers
come and Steve Buscemi just like rolls
on up to the house in Broad [__]
daylight looking through the window
she's just watching and she's just
watching it like just completely shocked
she's like who's this dude let's bust
through the damn glass and comes right
at her oh my God no survival is no sir
no
preservation instincts well I mean she
did have the wherewithal to like run up
the stairs and then she faked them out
by like opening the bathroom window like
she had jumped out which did actually
work and then she hid in the tub so she
did actually kind of have some kind of
thing but yeah after that she just she
ran out the [__] and then like fell down
the stairs I guess she just couldn't
believe it but the dude had a [__]
bag on his head yeah I'd have gone
straight for the guns [__] what the [__]
is no you know that's a bad guy anybody
covering their face yeah I mean yeah and
especially like if they come up on your
house in the broad daylight they clearly
do not give a [__] like Jason oh you're
the bad guy bro yeah
I saw that movie I grew up your kid take
it out no matter what but yeah you're
gonna [__] go down in a hail a
gunfire [__] yeah but yeah I just I
don't know I just thought that was a
really interesting decision like what
they did with her character I don't like
blame her for being like that though
because like I said she was completely
shocked I guess which he would be I
suppose if you're just sitting there in
the middle of [__] afternoon and like
some dude in The Mask so I mean but yeah
but um
you know she just kind of gets randomly
shot at the end they actually they don't
even you don't even know she's dead
until later because bashemi comes in
after he got shot in the face with the
money and she's just laying on the floor
and you can't really see her head or
anything like that so you don't know if
she's dead or not and he's just like
what and he's just like oh what happened
to her and it's like oh she wouldn't be
quiet or she wouldn't shut up but they I
didn't know if he just like knocked her
out or if he killed her but then like
later on when uh when Marge is like
talking to talking to him like you're
led to assume that that she got killed
but you know so uh so yeah this was um
this was really fun movie to revisit
because I like I said I'm pretty sure I
saw this in the theater when it first
came out and then I saw it again on
cable or I rented it or something like
that so I've seen it a couple of times
since then and I don't know I mean it's
definitely one of their best movies I
think and I mean a lot of their movies
are great but I had forgotten how
[__] funny this movie was that's a
good movie it's
um like I said it's a very specific kind
of humor and admittedly it's probably
much funnier if you're actually from the
Midwest and like recognize a lot of the
stuff but I know enough about the
Midwest and about that culture that I
can kind of see where they're coming
from with it so it is like very funny to
me and like I said the funniest thing to
me is just the whole juxtaposition of
everyone being like super over the top
polite and nice and then like having to
deal with this
with this [__] horrible scheme gone
wrong I don't know why but like the
funniest scene to me and the one that
stuck other than the wood chipper scene
which is Iconic for some reason the the
scene that
stayed with me the longest that was one
of the main ones that I remembered was
when Marge who actually doesn't show up
in the movie until half an hour in and
she's like kind of I don't know she's
kind of the main character because
Jerry's kind of the main character too
but she doesn't actually even show up
until like not halfway through the movie
but like half an hour into the movie
where she kind of gets to the first
crime scene like where the state trooper
and the and the two witnesses got shot
and she's like looking at the crime
scene and like you know sorting
everything out like correctly as it
turns out like she's like oh yeah this
is what happened and that was like she
you know susses it all out and she kind
of like bends over and her partner's
like oh you see something down there
Marge she's like no I just think I'm
gonna barf
because she's pregnant and then she just
like sits there she's like well that
fast now I'm hungry again and there's
like such great scenes like throughout
where her and her husband are like going
to the all-you-can-eat Smorgasbord like
just [__] plates full of food and
they're just eating them and it's just I
don't know like little details like that
like character stuff is like really
funny to me and then there's this that
whole little subplot with
that guy that I guess she went to school
with whose name is Mike and then she
meets up with him in the restaurant like
when she goes to the Twin Cities and he
tells her this sob story about oh how he
had a wife he married this girl that
they both knew in high school and then
like she died of Leukemia and all this
other kind of stuff and she's like oh no
that's terrible and all this other stuff
but then she finds out the next day that
he made that all up yeah and a lot of I
ca I kind of feel like a lot of people
were like why was that scene even in
there because it doesn't have anything
to do with the main plot which it kind
of doesn't but I think what I think why
that scene is in there
is because I think that was the point
that marches that Marge realized that
you can't take everyone at face value I
think that's what because she had
already interviewed Jerry once at this
point and I don't think she was
initially suspicious of him
but after she met up with this mic guy
and he told her this story and she
believed it at first but then found out
later it's like no that chick's still
alive it's like he's he wasn't married
to her like what the [__] is even he has
mental problems and so I think that made
her realize oh well maybe I should go
back and talk to Jerry again because she
goes back and like interviews Jerry
again like after that incident so I
think that was kind of like an inciting
incident that didn't have anything to do
with the main plot but that kind of
sort of like just informed her character
a little bit that it's like oh well you
can't take every everything everybody
says like at face value so I should go
check that out again and that's kind of
when she Cracks the Case when she goes
back and interviews Jerry a second time
because he gets like super nervous and
then like he [__]
runs out of the interview and like takes
off and like does some suspicious [__]
and that's when she kind of gets to the
bottom of the whole thing
yeah Oracle said it's very important
Mike is a liar like Jerry is a liar yeah
exactly exactly that's I kind of feel
like that's why that scene was in there
even though yeah it doesn't seem like it
has anything to do with the main plot
like it seems like it's just a
digression but
um let me see
Prowler needs a jump on yeah that's what
they're all saying yeah Marge is the
good guy of the story she definitely is
and I think she's she's really I think
one of the best characters that
um the Coen Brothers have ever put in a
movie and that part was written
specifically for her because I don't
know if you I mean I don't know if you
know but she's married to Joel Cohen
they actually they actually met on Blood
Simple and which was their first movie
that they because she was in that too
she was also great in that video one of
the other
it's another Super believable
heroine story of a female hero that that
wins it's a it's it's a more comedic
adaptation of what you would see with
like Ellen Ripley from Aliens it's on
that part very believable character yeah
and she's like like I said I like that
she's not overtly a badass she's just
like a regular person like doing her job
but you know honesty is very important
to her Integrity is very important to
her class yeah she's just like a decent
person and she's gonna get the job done
um and she's not gonna complain about it
like I like too that she's very pregnant
in the movie She's seven months pregnant
I guess because at the end they say that
it's two more months before the baby's
born but um but she doesn't really ask
anybody to like make accommodations for
her or she doesn't like you know she
just kind of gets on with it like you
would do she just gets up and does her
job she's not and she's always kind of
like in a good mood she has like a sunny
disposition she throws over he almost
throws up goes well that passed yeah now
I'm hungry
because she just like eats it eats like
the whole movie it's just like super
super funny but uh I don't know just
like I just find her character like
really really charming and like I said I
kind of feel like a lot of people felt
the same way which you know like I said
that's why she got the Oscar and well
deserved right there I love Francis
because Doom said yeah he I guess he
agreed agrees with me about her about
her character and that she wasn't
machoized either she was female yeah
just like like Ripley was Ripley wasn't
machuized she was just a woman competent
woman
yeah which I like I like that kind of
thing where she's just like I said it's
just somebody doing their job yeah it's
not you know she's just superhuman or a
superhero you know type day yeah I mean
I get where that comes from but
it's it's good to just kind of just show
a character that's just a regular ass
person just doing a regular ass job
um but still like does cool [__] but
still does cool [__] and like I said
it's not over the top it's not
unbelievable it's not she's not doing
anything unbelievable that she said too
that um they had the that pregnant belly
that they put on her she said it was a
whole onesie thing it had boobs on it
and everything and she's like the belly
part was filled with a bird bird seed
like so it would be heavy so she would
like move more like a pregnant woman and
they said that the boobs had silicone in
them and she left them in her trailer
overnight in Minnesota and the silicone
froze and like exploded
like while they were shooting a seed
they said that on the [__] on the
documentary and I'm just like oh so I
guess they had to remade like exploding
boobies you know what I mean because
there's a funny video on YouTube called
um I think it's called like 10 things
you probably didn't know about Fargo or
something like that and he talked about
that on there but I thought that was
like super funny
um yeah Oracle said considering Marge is
a small town Elio she's a great
detective yeah she's kind of and
somebody said earlier that uh she's kind
of like the female Columbo yeah because
she I like that that scene where she
comes at the at the beginning and she's
able to correctly assess like what
happened at the scene just from like the
footprints and the way that the cars are
and everything like that and she's right
about everything and then like her
partner you know he's saying oh it's you
know they said they saw a tan Cutlass
Sierra and it's like had DLR on the
plate and it's like so we're doing this
APB on cars that have DLR whatever the
plate and she's like I'm not sure I 100
agree with your police work there Lou
she's like dealer that's dealer plates
dlrs dealer plates and he's just like oh
geez you know what I mean because she's
but she's really nice about it like when
she like corrects him so I thought that
was like super funny too but like I said
there's just little touches like that
that really inform all the characters
that I think make this movie so good
yeah that's what Oracle said and she's a
good boss she doesn't make her partner
feel bad about the DLR mistake yeah she
doesn't yell at him nothing like that
and then she just kind of makes a little
joke about it like oh you know [__]
happens uh she handled that so well yeah
and that's I like I said I think that's
why she's such a great character and
there's not really a lot of characters
like her in
Cinema I feel like you know she was very
original
but yeah so uh are you ready to wrap it
up yep yeah I'm glad you like this movie
too because I really because I have a
great suggestion I really like this
movie and I had been wanting to do it
for a while so I'm really glad that's
sent it to us and like I said we'll
probably do some more Cohen Brothers I
want to do I did Blood Simple
um and we've done No Country for Old Men
and we've done some other ones Big
Lebowski yeah I'd like to do Barton Fink
although you might not like that because
that one's a little bit weird but um
it's kind of surreal and we haven't done
like Oh Brother Where Art Thou or oh
it's a great movie I like that one yeah
he did that too yeah yeah that's them
it's just uh Miller's Crossing yeah it's
Odysseus yeah yeah in the South yeah
yeah yeah that would be a good one to do
actually we should do it yeah because I
haven't seen it in a long time but yeah
the Cyclops
um do hail Caesar yeah maybe we could
um or or the man who wasn't there that
was a good movie too I haven't seen that
in a long time but I remember liking
that one a lot but yeah they've made a
[__] ton of good movies they've made a
[__] ton of good movies
um but yeah so I guess we'll wrap it up
thank you again very much Santa for
sending us the movie uh so tomorrow is
Monday and that means it's a haunting
Mondays we're going to do I think the
only one from season three that we
haven't done yet which is hidden Terror
we just remember that one we just
watched it recently you'll know which
one it is when I uh it's it's the one
with the guy that buys the house and
then um his friend goes there to paint
and she gets all depressed and
everything oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
um which I think we watched a couple
months ago it you know we were gonna do
it for the show but then we ended up
doing another episode because somebody
told me it's like oh you didn't do
hidden Terror yes yet and I was like
yeah we did and then I looked and I was
like oh no I guess we didn't all right
so that's the one we're gonna do so
we're gonna do hidden Terror tomorrow
um Ben said Miller's Crossing is the
best gangster film of all time yeah we
should probably do that like I said they
made so many [__] good movies man and
it's like we really need to get to a lot
of there's a lot of movies we need to
get to you know what I mean uh but yeah
so hopefully you guys have enjoyed this
discussion about Fargo and uh hopefully
you can join us for haunting Mondays
tomorrow we're gonna be talking about
hidden Terror and we'll see you guys
again tomorrow evening
bye